mind your decisions I'm presh tal Walker
in 1995 and 1996 advanced math students
from 16 countries took a standardized
test this is the hardest question that
only 10% solved correctly a string is
wound symmetrically around a circular
rod the string goes exactly four times
around the rod the rod has a
circumference of four and a length of 12
what is the length of the string pause
the video if you'd like to give this
problem a try and when you're ready keep
watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
I will present two different ways to
solve this problem let's get started
using calculus first we will rotate the
entire rod so that it stands vertically
then we will make the rod a transparent
surface so we can see the path of the
string now let's set up a coordinate
system of x y&z
the rod has a circumference equal to
four which means its radius will be
equal to two over pi the bottom of the
rod is along the plane Z is equal to 0
therefore the top of the rod will be
along the plane Z is equal to 12 we can
now describe the path of the string
using parametric equations X is equal to
R cosine T y is equal to R sine T since
the helix goes around four times and
since the period of sine and cosine is
2pi we must have T going between 0 and 8
pi in order that Z goes between 0 and 12
we have that Z is equal to 1.5 over pi
multiplied by T with these equations we
can use the arc length formula it'll be
the following integral we will carefully
calculate each derivative and then we
will simplify underneath the square root
from here sine squared of T plus cosine
squared of t is equal to 1 we thus
simplify further and we get the
following integral to evaluate it we
take 5 over 2 pi multiplied by 8 pi
which simplifies to be 20 and that's our
answer
this method does work but there are
plenty of opportunities to make mistakes
so let's learn a much simpler way to
solve this problem using a trick we will
cut this cylinder horizontally as shown
then imagine unwrapping this rod and
flattening it out at the same time the
cylinder will transform into a rectangle
and the string will transform into four
diagonal lines since the rod had a
circumference equal to 4 the height of
the cylinder will be equal to 4 we then
notice the length of this rectangle is
divided into four horizontal segments
that are each equal to X therefore we
have 4x is equal to 12 this means X is
equal to 3 we
need to calculate the following length
which is the hypotenuse of a right
triangle you might know the famous
Babylonian three four five triple or you
can calculate the length using the Gogu
theorem we get that the hypotenuse has a
length equal to five we thus have a
string that's equal to four diagonal
segments that are each equal to five
therefore it the length of the string is
equal to five times four which equals 20
know calculus required and that's our
answer thanks for making mind your
decisions one of the best channels on
YouTube as always thanks for watching
and thanks for your support
[Music]